what's up mary how are we doing hi how
are you
so good what's going on this morning
okay so i am 27
my husband is 26. we've been together
for a decade but we just got married
three months ago
we have a four-year-old daughter and
i'm working two jobs 65 hours a week
and he's working he's working part-time
and that's it um
that was i'm not laughing at you sort of
i'm laughing with you
um yeah but kind of at you
and the way you said that was awesome
just and that's it
so how can i help today i'm sure there's
a bunch of ways i could help but not
gonna help
well he also he wants to go to school
for something technical
so he can start a good career okay and
be making most of the money
and i am wanting to just like get an
apartment so we can like
we're living in his parents old house
rent free okay
um so do they live in the house too is
it just y'all too
no it's just us too and our daughter
okay and
um i'm just wanting to move out and get
an apartment i found one
it's 25 of my take-home pay
um we haven't combined incomes because
he's kind of against that
which so and normally in these
situations
i would walk through a series of
questions
like that start with your husband
your new husband of three months sounds
like he is
um a child sounds like he's a teenager
and
he's still living in a teenage mind
i'm going to be honest with you when i
got married i got married really young
i still had a teenage mind i still had a
idea that i was just going to go to work
and then go to the gym and
like my wife was a glorified roommate i
hadn't wrapped my head around it yet
okay
and so i don't want to to hop all over
this guy yet
but you're the person i'm talking to
and so my question to you is you've
known this dude for a decade
he's been the father of your daughter
for four years certainly this isn't a
surprise
no it's not so you married him knowing
that
this was who you were getting right it's
not like he bait and switched you right
he has grown up his parents were paying
most of his bills
he is slowly taking them on but my
problem
is i want to get an apartment so that we
can just kind of jump off the cliff
and land on our own feet instead of
constantly having that
extra help that they give him
i refuse help from my parents even if i
need it like i'll sell
stuff online you know like i obviously
got another job
so so it's before you just jump off
anything
you guys have to have a plan because one
of you is going to jump and the other
one's not going to
or one of you is going to jump and
you're going to grab the other one and
drag them down
and that always ends up just in a pile
of bodies at the bottom of a cliff
okay and have you ever
like sat down with him and said what's
your vision for this thing
and i know that may sound ridiculous to
some women listening to this
thinking about the guys that they're
with right now and i know there are guys
mowing their yards or driving right now
listening this going
dude i cannot have a w what is our
vision conversation with my wife
she would never have that conversation
so put yourself in that
in in that space you and him go camping
one weekend
and it's just like dude what are we
doing
what would that conversation be like or
maybe you've had it
i did have that this past weekend and
he he's very optimistic he's like yeah
i'm gonna go to college and get this
career and then
you can quit your jobs and stay home and
you know all that so
on monday of this week did he start
looking up colleges and and sending
applications because it's not christmas
he can be in a program by january
right yeah he he has and his mom and him
have talked
but that's the thing is like she's
constantly helping him she's like okay
i'll pay for your college
instead of letting him like think about
how he could do it
well i'm not if if a parent is going to
reach out and be supportive
i don't want to just say no to that out
of hand right if it comes with strings
and it comes with expectations that
mom is going to continue to run your new
married life
yeah i'm not taking that money and i'm
going to be really vocal in my home
about my spouse taking that money
but if a parent's going to help that in
and of itself isn't a bad thing
and so you have a young kid you have a
young marriage and
mom says hey i'll help with tuition but
son you're gonna have to work your butt
off
and you're gonna have to really problem
is she's willing to pay it
she's always paid for like everything i
know but here's the thing
you knew this coming in i know
and so part of me well i mean my heart's
broken away the
bad qualities because i saw the good i
saw the good qualities
are the good still there oh yeah they're
still yeah
so at the end of the day let's take like
the work thing is a big deal for me
everyone like we were made to work um
not working leads to all kinds of
downstream mental health issues and
relational challenges and just
in like self-worth issues male
female everybody deals with this
but let's back up is he a good dad does
he love you
yes yes he's a great dad he loves that
little baby
yep and i've got two definitions i love
one that talks about a lot
and one that shows up and shows up looks
like getting a job
shows up also looks like getting up in
the middle of the night and changing
diapers and
being supportive when wife is off
working 65 hours a week
cleaning bottles um making sure dinner's
ready so he helps with that kind of
stuff
yes he does that's awesome okay so what
you're telling me is you've got a guy
that's got integrity and character
and he doesn't have the tools yes
right and so two things one he needs to
call me
so i can talk directly to him okay
because you and i can't solve his
problem
right what you and i can do is this
number one
at some at some existential level 35 000
foot view of this
you knew the bed you were you were
getting into right
you knew and so what you're asking him
to do
is to make a decade a character change
overnight after three months
um you're asking him to become a
different person it's a fair ask and
it's a right ask
but it is a tall order at this point
right
yeah and so what i want you to do is
to set up so you guys had the
conversation this weekend that's not a
one-off shot
so today i want you to say
i want to follow up on our conversation
we had this weekend
saturday morning we're going to let
grandma come pick up
our four-year-old or we're gonna let
four-year-old i don't know play
four-year-old things or when
four-year-old takes
nap number one um in the morning we're
gonna we're gonna meet we're gonna go
out on the front porch
it's not super freezing yet in arkansas
here we're gonna go out on the front
porch
and we are going to
talk through this because
um we're going to set up some metrics
right we've got the dream part
you said you want to go to school you
want to have a job and you want me to be
able to stay home
awesome then we're going to start
putting things in order
when are you going to first send off
your applications
i'm expecting you that we're gonna start
school january so we're gonna have to
get some child care issues i want you to
start putting some meat on that skeleton
okay okay and that means for the next
couple of days until you have that
meeting i want you to be thinking about
the things in your mind that you want
answered
what's the date on this who's going to
pay for it what's the
time expectation let's look at your
schedule because we're going to get a
schedule
and for a technical school in
fayetteville that's a sign up sheet
right there's
a couple of giant universities there oh
yeah and there are some technical
schools all around that area
you're going to get signed up you could
have a course list
by friday you could have a course list
by first thing next week literally
signed up
ready to go and then you're gonna have
to figure out scheduling
right are you gonna cut back on your job
are you gonna keep working and you're
gonna need some help from the in-laws
all those kind of things and you're
gonna have to get over your pride part
you're a newlywed couple you've got a
little baby
let grandparents help you if it's
healthy don't just say no just to say no
right that that ends up being here's the
thing it ends up being the same
issue just on the way other side of the
spectrum
like yeah i need all the help i need
none of your help
it's both silly okay yeah
and one feels tougher than the other
they're not they're both
inaccurate you both need a little bit of
help you're a newlywed couple even
though you've been together forever
you've got a newborn in that house and
y'all are still trying to figure out
what life's gonna look like so accept
the help if it doesn't come with a bunch
of
character and value strings to it okay
and then i want you to ask him the
following
i want you to ask him for permission to
hold him accountable
i want you to ask him um the following
hey i'm asking a lot of you because
you're gonna have to be a different guy
now
we're married we have a baby you're
gonna have to
begin to break away from your mom and
i'm asking
if i can speak into your life as your
wife
i'm asking you to when you get nervous
and frustrated
to not hide with video games to not just
quit school
but come tell me and say i'm being
vulnerable here and i don't know how to
do this because mom never made me
dad didn't teach me how but i'm kind of
exhausted right now
and then you can give him the speech i'm
working 65 hours i'm exhausted y'all can
do that that y'all can have that dance
together
but i want you to tell him proactively
i want to be a part of helping us come
together i want to be a part of helping
you become a great
great husband become a great man and i
know it's going to be a journey for us
because you've been this way for a long
time
and i'm all in if you're all in i want
him i want you to tether into him okay
okay and then man you be you be firm on
the accountability
let's get some dates let's get some
dollar amounts let's get some here's
what this is going to do to our
schedules
let's get some of that on paper on the
calendar and then let's get ready to
rock and roll
and again he sounds like a guy of
integrity and character that has just
simply been mothered to death and he's
got no tools
and you signed up for it you knew what
you were getting you signed up for it
um you're gonna have to be about
teaching him tools and you're gonna have
to let him grow up and you're gonna have
to hold him accountable
and you're gonna have to let him hold
you accountable okay awesome
mary i've got high faith in you guys i
got high faith in you
even though you jumped into a pool
knowing there was no water in it
you knew there was no water in it but
you jumped anyway all right so it hurt
when you hit
and now we're gonna get up dust our
stuff off and we're gonna get into the
business of being connected so good for
you mary